اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار قال الرئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان اسرائيل تفاجئ
ايران دوما وسوف تفاجئ كل اعدائها حسب
تعبيره وكان رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قال ان ايران تقدمت في تخصيب اليورانيوم
على نحو غير مسبوقا واضاف ان اسرائيل
لديها القدره على ضرب ايران وما تحاول ان
تبنيه حولها
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان
سلاح الجو نفذ عملياته خلال المواجهه
الاخيره في غزه بنجاح كبير ودعا سلاح الجو
للبقاء على اهبه الاستعداد
المقابل حظر مسؤول ايراني من ان استهداف
منشات بلاده النوويه يعني اشعال حرب واسعه
تتحمل اسرائيل مسؤوليتها وقال المسؤول
الايراني للجزيره ان كلام اسرائيل عن
استعدادها لضرب منشات ايران النوويه هو
ارهاب رسمي يقابل بصمت دوري
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه انه لا معنى لاي تهديدات تشمل
الصناعه النوويه الايرانيه واضاف ان هذه
الصناعه باتت محليه ومتجذره حسب قوله واكد
ان العدو يدرك انه لا يمكن ازاله قدرات
ايران النوويه
افدى حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه بان طائره بدون
طيار القت عبوه متفجره على احدى الطرقات
في المقاطعه واشار الى عدم تسجيل اصابته
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت القضاء
على من تبقى ممن وصفتهم بمجموعات القوميين
الاوكرانيين الذين هاجموا مقاطعه
واضافت انه تم صد المجموعات الاوكرانيه من
خلال الضربات الجويه ونيران المدفعيه
في المقابله كدت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان بلادها لا تقوم باي عمليات
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وان من يقف وراء ذلك
مواطنون روس مستاءون من نظام بوتين بسبب
حربه على اوكرانيا على حد تعبيرها
اما منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي فقال ان واشنطن لا
تشجع ولا توفر اي دعم للهجوم على الاراضي
الروسيه
في السودان تراجعت حده المعارك في اليوم
الاول من هدنه الايام السبعه وقد شهدت
مناطق ام درمان والابيض اطلاق نار متقطع
بعد ساعات من دخول الهدنه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيز التنفيذ
واكدت واشنطن انها تناقش مع مجموعه مراقبه
الهدنه تقارير عن الانتهاكات وقالت الامم
المتحده انها تسعى الى توسيع عملياتها
الانسانيه وحذرت من التداعيات الاقليميه
للصرع
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]